for people for the few people who aren't
familiar with your work how do you
describe what you do and what you do
online or what you do in education well
the Khan Academy is most known for this
collection of videos that I like a
somewhat famous they started making for
my my cousins and then they caught on
people who are not my cousin started
watching them but but by the time it
kind of got serious traction and I had
quit my former job in finance to do this
full-time set it up as a not-for-profit
our support has really kind of allowed
us to focus on not only the videos not
only translating the videos but trying
to build an entire interactive platform
so students can get instruction do
practice if they have a teacher or
parent who can be their coach they can
those those folks will get information
on where the students are at what type
what are their strengths what are their
weaknesses and so the Khan Academy on
one level it's kind of free tutoring for
anybody it's a not-for-profit everything
is free our mission is a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere but on a deeper level it's it's
we've kind of fallen into this situation
and it kind of speaks to where we are in
history maybe where well it seems like
we're catalyst for helping people think
about what a classroom could be now and
I've never been a big believer that it
should be virtual only but it feels like
now the virtual can handle certain parts
of the equation it frees up the
classroom to do maybe maybe more
interesting things and what dimensions
exactly do you think virtual education
or online does arguably better than
direct instruction from classroom
teacher and it's it's it's a kind of a
careful answer just because i think the
ideal is you have absolutely you have
both the real ideals if you had a
one-on-one with a with a human being but
that's not practical the only landlords
and Dukes had that hundreds of years ago
what what we're seeing is students when
they are getting together with people in
a physical environment we think the best
use of that is not the lecture the one
piece fits all lecture the best use of
that time is for the human beings to
actually interact they're all in the
room together and so we're online
strength is
is on delivering what used to be that
lecture in a way that it's not one piece
fits all anymore so that a student can
pause and repeat at their own time at
their own pace if they're embarrassed by
maybe they're in eighth grade and they
forgot something from fourth grade they
don't have to have the guts to raise
their hand in class they can just look
you know look at those concepts no one's
going to judge them if they're ready to
move ahead they could move ahead
software is also really good at kind of
generating exercises grading the
exercises doing a lot of the logistics
that frankly take teachers away from the
actual teaching part of their job and so
what we're saying is in a traditional
classroom a lot of a teacher's time is
spent giving this lecture to a bunch of
students oftentimes the classroom is
fairly passive at those moments a lot of
the teachers time is kind of the
administrative work of writing exams
grading exams and maybe ten fifteen
percent of their time is spent with the
actual one-on-one interaction or small
group interaction with students we're
saying if this if the if with technology
we can take a lot of the information
delivery we can take a lot of the
logistics a lot of the problem set
creation and grading off of a teacher's
plate a hundred percent of their time
could be the the one-on-one connections
with students and the small group
interactions I wonder is part of the
issue that it's the sort of the
one-to-many kind of dissemination of
information which tends to be the
prevailing model of instruction that it
that is somewhat imperfect anyway it's
sort of like whether you're doing it in
the lecture hall in front of 500 people
or we've got 500 students online yeah
and you know that the irony here near
you're talking to someone who you know
sense that down and made three thousand
videos or attitude I was 3,200 now but
the most important part of an education
is not the lecture / the videos the most
important part of the education is doing
problem solving and interacting with
people and asking questions and
answering other people's questions and
in traditional classrooms you that tends
to get squeezed out you get a little bit
of it but it gets squeezed out by the
the passive lecture so I agree with you
I think a lecture is an imperfect thing
it I think gets a little bit better when
you make it on demand when you allow to
cater to a student space and then
technology can also understand what's
working what's not working
start to collect data on what's
effective what's not traditional lecture
gets very little of that data textbooks
get very little of that data now with
online you can have it but I think that
the main focus is in submit of the irony
here is that the technology enables the
classroom to become more interactive
more human and and for me you know
there's always there always these
debates of today's technology good is it
a cure-all is it silver bullet or is it
bad and you know things just gathered us
and for me the question isn't should or
should you not use technology the
question is well what is the ideal
learning experience and you try to
answer that question to me it's a you
know it's it's experience focused on the
student cater to the students needs
works at the student space and then once
you answer that when they when they when
they're out other human beings are
interacting with them and so you say
okay that's the idea now can we do it
and thirty fifty hundred years ago you
couldn't economically do it you would
have to be quite well off to have that
type of attention to personalized
education but now I think the answer is
we can do it we can personalize it in a
practical way the instructors have not
been brought up obviously in an online
environment the vast majority of them
but they have been brought up with the
concept of differentiated instruction
and I wonder there are some who would
argue well I can adapt my lecture to
students questions to blank stares in
the desks that I'm looking at is there
are there instances where perhaps in a
smaller environment where maybe a
lecture can be equal to or better than
you know a video lecture style of
delivery yeah absolutely there are
certain circumstances I think if you
have a very small seminar type situation
that's highly interactive then that wins
and actually I would say that's not a
lecture anymore that's actually what we
would want to see class time used for I
think there's also moments where shared
experience is very powerful and and i
would say that falls more in the
category of inspiring your TED Talks and
inspirational speech I think they're
there is valued of having many people in
the room and having that shared that
shared moment but I think for things
that are intellectually deep things that
are
hard for people to get their head around
some person might get it faster than
another person I mean me and you we can
watch a speech at a high level speech
and we'll all get it but if we're doing
calculus we're doing chemistry you might
get it faster than me I might get it
faster than you it's nearly impossible
frankly if you get even more than 10 or
15 students to cater to where where
every student is and the only
information that a teacher currently has
is trying to read the blank stares
trying to read how engage the students
are and you know there have been studies
that the average lecture is teaching at
the 23rd percentile because they're
making sure that no one is is falling
behind and I point out you might say oh
well at least twenty three percent of
the students are are getting it but no
the reality is seventy-seven percent are
bored and then twenty-two percent it's
going too fast for so you're only
catering to one percent and so I won't
make a blanket statement that it's
always better but i will i will say that
most of the time when you have human
beings together it's better for them to
interact with each other to ask
questions of each other than for them to
just kind of sit passively and be given
a lecture and a lot of times when people
say well in a live lecture you can ask
questions and I say yeah absolutely
today in a traditional lecture hall
that's maybe five percent of class time
and that's usually only the bravest
people in the class and sometimes even
the question might not be appropriate
for everyone we'd like to see rally
where it's a hundred percent of the
class time and it's not just asking the
teacher questions not just asking the
TAS questions but it's also asking your
peers questions where the where the
students themselves get that deeper
experience of explaining things to it to
their to their colleagues you see the
they're still being 50-50 split maybe
that's not the right percentage but at
least a part that's online apart this in
class have you heard people or what's
your response to people saying well you
know maybe we can do more of the
discussion part online as well whether
it's through chat rooms and skyping or
whatever what's the what's the problem
or why should that remain in the
classroom or why not you know ship that
into the online environment as well I
think we should all experiment on what
what type of social experience is
constructive social experiences you have
online I think in some domains you know
doing
Scott could be very valuable for foreign
language I mean the gold standard has
always been immersion if you can't
afford immersion you skype with somebody
who speaks that language and maybe maybe
you could get interesting results you
know we see on our site we have we have
six million students use the Site every
month we want them to interact with each
other we want them to answer their
questions with that sand and that's
incredibly valuable for someone who
maybe does not have someone else to
interact with they don't have access to
a kind of a rich environment but it I
think the technology would have to go
very very long way to come close to what
you could get with a very rich classroom
environment that's led by an inspiring
teacher but when i say lead not mean
lectured by the inspiring teacher but
really mentored and coached by an
inspiring teacher given that these are a
different set of skills from teachers
from what teachers have been really
brought up in do you have a vision for
how to kind of get to the sort of 21st
century flipped classroom instructor
that we would need to do this yeah and
it's an open question III don't know
hundred percent I mean it's actually
exciting to be here at a school that is
so focused on education I suspect a lot
of the answer might be four for the the
Future teacher's to experience it
themselves for them to understand it and
for them to viscerally feel the
difference between being lectured at and
being able to engage with the content
and have conversations with their peers
and discuss it as a deeper level but I
think we're just we're at the very early
stages I mean in my opinion or it seems
like a lot of the adoptions happening
faster than I would have guessed we're
being used in 20,000 classrooms right
now and this is really just over the
last couple of years and we have two
people engaged directly with classrooms
were a very small organization so it
seems like there's a hunger out there a
lot of the teachers we talk to this is
kind of the direction they've always
wanted to be and they've wanted to they
got into the profession because they
wanted to connect with students they
wanted to you know they wanted to be
that teacher that takes that student
from you know a certain attitude to a
were they taking ownership of their life
and and they found it difficult when
they have 30 faces that they have to
kind of lecture at all right and one
thing that I've heard as sort of a
concern from from teachers is that there
might be a
well I maybe I'll put it this way the
concerns have not come just from
teachers but the online learning often
gets sold as a cost-saving you know as
something that okay well we public
education is very expensive what can we
do to save money do you think it is a
viable way to do education less
expensively I I kind of I I don't know
ms is a simple answer I mean I know for
my own kids I don't want them online
only and I and I you know the way I view
it if education was perfect we should
think about how we can then you know for
making a great car we can then think
about how to streamline the factory or
whatever we're doing but you know the
reality and you know there's a million
alarmist articles have come out about
all the reasons why we should worry
about education and so in my mind I
would not try to de resource the problem
I would try to maybe hold resources
constantly maybe even potentially
increase them but try to get but try to
have better outcomes and so I view
technology is much more of given
whatever resources you have and you know
it's hard to argue that you're ever
putting too much too many resources in
education given whatever resources you
have how do we actually optimize
outcomes you've had a good time doing
the videos that you mean I don't think
you do as 3,000 of them if you didn't
like doing them yes no I like doing them
a lot yes I do you have any particular
favorites that you were sort of like you
know you've heard or have you heard from
people who are particularly fond of a
certain video oh you know there's a
bunch i mean well i think one of you
know people ask me like what's the trick
how do you yeah and and and I say well
the video that I'm doing I could try to
convince myself that's my favorite video
so that you literally have like you know
you hear the energy you hear the
excitement and you can't understate how
important those cues are for the student
if the lecturer themselves does not care
about it the student immediate we're
very sensitive to that if you're saying
the next step in this equation I mean
who's going to care about that and so I
think it's very important for the
lecturer themselves to feel excited that
they get to do this but there's all
sorts of topics i'm a real big fan of
the cosmology videos it was a reason for
me to learn a lot of cosmology and
really understand it and it's something
that always fascinated me
I but I get into the finance videos my
old life I was in an analyst at an
investment firm and obviously there's a
certain part of me that gets very
passionate about that I love doing the
history videos i love doing a video i
like i like doing it all you get some
pushback from educators who are like
well he didn't go to education school he
didn't you know do you feel like maybe
teaching is not as hard as people make
it up to me well i actually isaac i
think it's probably harder than people
make it out to be and you know depending
on what you call a teacher it's you know
you can determine whether i am one or
whether i'm a content creator I don't
have to or I mean depending how you do
it you know I don't have 30 live
students that I'm trying to cater to
that I'm you know some of them might
have some problem at home some of them
have some issue some are struck you know
that is a that is a nuanced and deep and
important role that I am NOT doing when
I just make a nice resource when I make
this this nice video hopefully it's an
engaging video it gets people excited
about the subject matter and and you
know I want to stress that I recently
met Wendy Kopp at dinner the founder of
Teach for America and she was telling me
that the single biggest determinant of
the teachers that they have in they
study this very carefully what are the
teachers that are showing outside
outsized gains and most people think is
going to be content delivery there is
some correlation if someone can deliver
a good lecture then their students tend
to do well but the one the thing that's
it that really moves the dial is a
teacher's ability to change the students
mindsets that to make the students
realize that they really have to take
ownership of their learning that they
really have to start thinking about
their futures and and when she said that
was like well I need to quote you and
I'm quoting her right now because that's
very consistent what we're saying
instead of five or ten percent of a
teacher's time being that that that
coach that inspiration and ninety
percent being the the content delivery
we want a hundred percent of a teacher's
time being that coach that inspiration
that that that person and the students
life that can change their their mindset
that can change their outlook that can
be that mentor and that's something I'll
never be able to do as a video creator
and you need a live human being for do
you think there's much of a stretch
between standing in front of a group
of 25 students and doing an exercise at
the board versus doing an exercise in a
YouTube video that's going to be seen at
home you know we've been we're and we're
constantly looking for folks to make
more and more videos and obviously
there's some incredible teachers out
there many many incredible teachers but
we found that there's a certain
nervousness once you record yourself and
you put it out there for the world to
see and comment on and so yes there
there is a difference when you I mean I
actually don't think about it when I
make a video I kind of just imagine my
cousin's listening and I think it just
makes it more intimate and warm
hopefully but we have seen folks who are
amazing teachers in the in physical form
but when they know they're being
recorded they tend to get a little
nervous and I think teachers are
accustomed to making relationships or
forming relationships with students that
they have right in front of them and
there's this uncertainty around well how
am I relating to how we're relating how
are students relating to me when they
see me on their computer and is that
obviously you started with your cousin
so I don't know if you ever sort of went
through that period of uncertainty yeah
no I go through that period of
uncertainty every time I upload a video
and and this is what's exciting these
days is I can upload a video now and
within an hour I'll get 50 comments from
kids all of all ages I shouldn't say
just kids all over the world and it
matters to me I mean it really helps me
if a few say well that really helped
that was exactly what I needed I've
gotten through that concept now and so
in that way I get much more direct
feedback you know I've done I've never
been a professional teacher but I've
done some teaching in college and you
know I used to give a lecture or teach a
class and the day would go but no
feedback and get I'd get insecure and
and that would happen and maybe at the
end of the term you might get one or two
students if you know if you're lucky who
might see how that was really helpful
you know thank you but you don't get
that direct feedback is as often and and
you know in online you get that feedback
for better or for worse I mean sometimes
the feedback can be harsh but once again
that that can only make you better would
you expect every instructor to produce
their own content or do you think that
there could be
to standardize repository that teachers
would draw from I I think both I mean
I'd like to see a world where every
instructor if they're not happy with
what they're seeing out in the world
that they are creating their own if they
hate I could do better than that I'd you
know that bet person is not covering
this nuance or this angle let me do
something with that said I can't imagine
over time the the content delivery you
know just as every teacher is not
writing their own textbook that you kind
of start to settle on it becomes
reasonably resource intensive now we can
actually use data and analytics to
figure out which of the the videos and
once again I think the videos are much
in some ways are analogous to the text
in a textbook but we can start to
measure how effective is and how
engaging is it and I could you know in
five or ten years we won't need
thousands of explanations of factoring a
polynomial we could have a handful that
have proven themselves to really engage
students and and and resonate with them
have one last question okay okay which
is the the level of work that this type
of education requires as opposed to what
teachers are accustomed to doing now
what I've heard from one instructor who
does sort of a hybrid kind of you know
does a little bit of both he's like well
this the classes that have an online
component you really have to develop all
those online pieces in advance and then
you still have all of the work of the
you know regular interaction with
students in short it sounds like it is
more work it may be worth it but do you
think that it is more work and perhaps
worth it or what's your view on that
what we're seeing is yeah I think today
in most schools especially i would say
public schools where teacher wants to do
something in this direction it is more
work for them today because to some
degree they have to serve two masters
they have to serve the traditional
master of this is the state curriculum
you have to do this in this week but the
same time they want to have the
flexibility and and and allow the
students to work at their own pace and
cater to the students so it is more work
for them today it's less work than if
they wanted to do a a student-centered
curriculum 10 years ago without any
technology with that said the direction
that everything seems to be get going is
that the tools are getting better you
know Khan Academy itself is nowhere near
being a perfect tool we have a list of
200 things that we need to fix about it
make it easier for teachers to use make
it easier for
to plan the curriculum we have to add a
lot more content so that people don't
have to go and fill in the gaps and
other places there's other people making
more and more tools so i suspect as the
tools get better as as kind of the the
curriculum becomes clearer i think this
adoption of the common core is actually
a huge opportunity because states have
adopted it it hasn't kind of fully gone
into implementation yet i think all of
these things are kind of converged the
technology is going to become more
usable and more accessible right now
teachers have to struggle with trying to
get the laptop cart for their class at
the right period hopefully a lot of
those things are going to solve
themselves over the next four or five
years so yes it's I would say it's
harder today but the teachers think it's
worth it but I would suspect 5 10 years
from now it might be easier than a
traditional model ok well thanks I
should probably wrap up now I could ask
you a lot or no no no great ok yeah it's
great questions I appreciate it